MAYBE THEY'RE WAITING FOR PUT IN
TO WAKE UP SO THEY CAN ASK HIM
WHAT TO DO.
♪ ♪
GEORGE SOROS IS A BILLIONAIRE,
BUT SOMEHOW HIS OWN MONEY ISN'T
ENOUGH TO FUND THE TOTALITY OF
HIS ANTI-AMERICAN AGENDA.
U.S. TAXPAYERS HAVE TO STEP IN
AND HELP AS WELL.
FEDERAL JUSTICE DOCUMENTS NEWLY
OBTAINED SHOW THAT IN 2016, THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION, WHOSE
MISDEEDS ARE JUST NOW COMING TO
LIGHT, GAVE ALMOST $9 MILLION TO
SUPPORT SOMETHING CALLED THE
EAST-WEST MANAGEMENT INSTITUTE.
ACCORDING TO JUDICIAL WATCH, THE
MONEY IS TO EMPOWER THE
SOCIALIST GOVERNMENT WHICH SPENT
A LOT OF TIME MAKING PEOPLE
MISERABLE.
ONE OF THE REASONS I'M SO GLAD
YOU'RE HERE AS YOU TIE A BOW ON
STORIES.
THERE'S A LOT THEY DID THAT WE
DON'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT.
TELL US THIS SMALL PIECE, WHAT
DID THEY DO IN ALBANIA AND WHY?
>> THERE SUPPORTING THOSE
SOCIALIST COMMUNIST GOVERNMENT
AND THEY'RE DOING IT WITH
TAXPAYER DOLLARS.
THEY'RE REDOING IT IN 2016 AND
THEY WERE EVEN DOING IT IN THE
FIRST PART OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IN 2017.
COSPONSORING SURVEYS OF THE
POPULATION THAT GENERATED 91% OF
THE SUPPORT IN FAVOR OF THE
PRO-GOVERNMENT PRO-SOROS
OPERATION THAT WOULD RESTRICT
THE INDEPENDENT JUDICIARY.
THEY WERE TRYING TO REFORM THE
JUDICIARY THAT WOULD PUT THEM
UNDER CONTROL OF THE SOCIALIST
GOVERNMENT THERE.
WHAT'S TROUBLING IS SOROS NEEDS
NO TAXPAYER MONEY TO DO ANY OF
THIS ADVOCACY WORK, BUT THERE
PARTNERING AND BASICALLY
ALLOWING SOROS TO SET OFF A
POLICY AGENDA.
AND SECONDLY, HIS OPERATIONS
ACCORDING TO THESE DOCUMENTS
WERE ALLOWED TO COME INTO THE
STATE DEPARTMENT AND PROVIDE
TECHNICAL REVIEWS OF OTHER
APPLICATIONS FOR OTHER
GOVERNMENT MONEY AND ALBANIA.
>> Tucker: GEORGE SOROS HATES
THE UNITED STATES AND I'M
JUDGING THAT BY THEIR PROJECT
THAT HE FUNDS.
ALL OF WHICH ARE DESIGNED TO
CHANGE THE COUNTRY THAT ARE
WORKING TOWARD U.S. INTERESTS.
WHY IN THE WORLD WOULD ANY
STATE DEPARTMENT GIVE MONEY TO
THIS KIND OF OPERATION?
>> WE HAVE FOUR LAWSUITS AT
ONE POINT, ALBANIA, ROMANIA, HE
IS ACTIVE AND HUNGRY, QUITE,
GUATEMALA, COLUMBIA.
THEY'RE VERY ACTIVE, DOESN'T
TAKE A LOT OF MONEY TO HAVE A
BIG IMPACT IN THESE COUNTRIES
AND THE GOVERNMENTS ARE UNDER
ASSAULT FROM A SOROS
STATE DEPARTMENT UNITY EFFORT TO
BRING SOCIALISM AND STOP
ANYTHING IN THE AREA OF REFORM,
CONSTITUTIONALISM.
THE SORT OF THINGS THAT
AMERICANS WOULD BE COMFORTABLE
WITH, SOROS GROUPS AREN'T.
HE'S A BILLIONAIRE.
HE DOESN'T NEED THE MONEY AND
WHEN YOU FIND IT IN ONE PLACE,
THAT MEANS YOU HAVE MORE MONEY
TO SPEND ELSEWHERE.
IF YOU DON'T LIKE WHAT HE'S
DOING HERE AT HOME, YOU SHOULD
KNOW IT'S BEING INDIRECTLY
SUBSIDIZED.
>> Tucker: HE'S GETTING
STATE DEPARTMENT MONEY IS THERE
ANY GROUP THAT GETS TAXPAYER
MONEY OF ANY KIND?
>> THEY DON'T ASK FOR IT, BUT
CERTAINLY THE STATE DEPARTMENT
IS NOT TERRIBLY INTERESTED IN
FUNDING GROUPS THAT ARE
ANTAGONISTIC TO THEIR AGENDA.
THIS IS ANOTHER WAY FOR THE
STATE DEPARTMENT TO STICK IT TO
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION BECAUSE
SOME OF THIS ACTIVITY WAS TAKING
PLACE IN EARLY 2017.
AGAIN, ATTACKING THE IDEA OF AN
INDEPENDENT JUDICIARY AND
ALBANIA.
THIS IS YOUR TAX DOLLARS AT WORK